like I'm out of solutions here I can
speak glibly about no-fly zone safe zone
but at this point I just understand this
administration is never going to do
anything to try and rescue the Syrian
people or prevent Assad Iran and Russia
from killing everybody they want to
Michael Weiss is a foreign affairs
reporter with extensive experience
covering the Middle East and Russia he's
a senior editor at The Daily Beast a
contributor to CNN and the author of the
New York Times bestseller
Isis inside the army of terror widely
viewed is the most comprehensive study
to date of the brutal Islamist entity
that controls a wide swath of land
between Iraq and Syria
we spoke with Weiss about the limits of
US interventionism in the region the
Syrian refugee crisis Russia's recent
bombing of Syrian rebels and how
President Obama's ambition for a nuclear
deal with Iran has exacerbated to chaos
Michael Weiss thanks so much for joining
us it's a pleasure thanks very much it's
an unspeakable complicated mess yeah it
is it's hard to pin down at all and and
you've been critical of the Obama
administration and the international
community for not acting sooner on the
problem in Syria but really what kind of
action could have taken place that
wouldn't have created like a an
analogous mess to the one we got right
now well look the historian never
traffic's and counterfactuals did you
make a fool of yourself right I will say
this in 2012/2013 hell even in late 2011
when they started using their Air Force
it would have been fairly simple to do a
no-fly zone in northern or southern
Syria you hear from the Pentagon all
this [ __ ] about their air defense
systems I'd lost track of how many times
the Israelis have bombed the [ __ ] out of
Syrian military installations targeted
and recently done it recently they hit
things in Damascus for Christ's sake and
sometimes they do it without even
entering Syrian airspace you know I've
talked to defected Syrian military
soldiers I've talked to generals who you
who'd served and fought the Israelis in
in in you know the 70s and they said
look all this equipment first of all
it's outdated and defunct it's
soviet-era stuff from the 60 70s we
never upgraded it secondly the people
operating it are morons third the United
States can easily work its way around it
when the Israelis bombed Assad's nuclear
program in Deir Ezzor in 2007 they they
first they did cyber warfare so they
scrambled all the radars then they
called Assad and they said
you can either lose your nuke program
today or your whole country and your
whole government today you pick so this
idea we couldn't take on Soviet systems
in northern Syria which is not even
where the build-up of anti-aircraft
systems were it's mostly in the West
against the Israelis this was just so no
would have protected would have you
would have you would have at least four
stalled some of the refugee crisis right
I mean people are fleeing into foreign
countries because they're not being
attacked by jets in foreign countries I
mean it's it's as simple as that
building ran it would've ran have seen
that as an act of war as imposing a
no-fly zone this is one of the reasons I
think that we did nothing apart from
Obama's own sort of political cast of
mine not wanting to get involved in the
Middle East wanting to pull out of it
he wanted this deal so badly with the
Iranians the nuclear deal you think was
inspiring his decisions did not want to
attack any Iranian interests be it in
Iraq or in Syria or wherever Iran took
over the security services of Iraq in a
slow-motion fashion at first while we
were still there and when we withdrew in
a very quick rapid fashion and now they
own Baghdad and they own southern Iraq
what is America's culpability in all
this how are we cooperating with Iran in
Syria right now well there are de facto
ally we've provided close air support to
Shia militias led by Qasem Soleimani so
we barely have diplomatic relations with
them and we have military cooperation as
well I mean it's deconfliction as we
like to call it the new euphemism du
jour right now you have no credible
non-sectarian intercessory force in Iraq
or in Syria you don't have the hundred
and first Airborne you don't have the
first Armored Division you don't have
people that Sunni tribes can warily
partner with against a Qi instead you
have Iran how about the Kurds the Kurds
they're not going I mean they have their
own interests right the first thing the
Kurds did very smartly when Isis blew
into Mosul in June 2014
they took over Kirkuk militarily they
had owned it more or less politically
already just by the nature of Iraqi
politics but they took it militarily
they big oil tow not just that that is
that is the the Jerusalem of Kurdistan
they'll never give it back to Iraq you
know one of the ironies of this refugee
crisis everyone says Isis is going to
smuggle in with sort of all the Muslims
that are coming over from Syria in Iraq
I've seen more evidence on social media
of Iraqi Shia militiamen coming over
basically deserting the war because
their exhaust
that I want to touch on a couple of
points about Syria first you mentioned
the Free Syrian Army John McCain was
very active in promoting them as the
last great hope in Syria but very few
people know who they are who are they
well it doesn't exist it's a catch-all
term right there are thousands of
different rebel groups and militias on
the ground in Syria but they have a
pleasant sounding name they have a
pleasant sounding name I mean and
originally it was known as the Facebook
Syrian army because they mostly existed
on social media right and when they were
mostly motivated just by opposition and
defense Assad's goons would come in bust
open the door of your house if you have
a wife or sister
shabiha would gang rape her in front of
you make you watch they take your son
spirit him away to some dungeon he'd be
gang-raped in prison and tortured have
his genitals electrocuted I mean women
in Assad's prisons they and they had
rats shoved into their vaginas according
to people who got out right according to
Human Rights Watch Amnesty so the
barbarism even though it's not being
exhibited we're not watching it on BBC
or CNN because Assad is not looking to
exhibit his atrocities unlike Isis it
doesn't mean they don't exist so these
are good optics though internationally
for the Free Syrian Army and that we're
just normal people we're businessmen and
we're fighting a brutal dictator yes but
a lot of these guys look even if we
classify them as Islamist it didn't mean
that they wanted to fly planes into the
World Trade Center or Freedom Tower as
it now is it didn't mean they wanted to
commit terrorist attacks against the
United States I mean they were desperate
they said look you know you intervened
in Libya you told Mubarak he had to go
you did all these things you smash
Saddam in Iraq why can't you help us you
know and if you don't want to give us a
no-fly zone fine give us weapons so we
can fight the regime what's the best
argument to not back them well that we
really don't know who they are or we
don't we shouldn't trust them because
the kind of government that they will
build and the ashes of us autism is not
any government we want to be partnered
with and right the weapons could
certainly end up in the hands of Isis
just like those weapons we gave to Iraq
well ironically the weapons that Isis
has confiscated in the main have been
american-made weapons given to the
Iraqis right on these tanks and for
rifles I've seen all this stuff for the
first two years of this civil war
everyone's like right so you've got Isis
and you've got Assad and they're
fighting each other know you've had
Assad and here Isis and both were
fighting the Free Syrian Army or other
rebel groups
and also killing activists and
protesters why because they have a
common objective the common objective is
to destroy any credible or Western
friendly or potentially Western friendly
opposition in the country so Assad this
goes back to his original propaganda
conceit he's always wanted to create
this this sort of dire dichotomy it's
either me or the people who will fly
planes into your buildings in New York
in fact Jane's defense 2014 they came
out with a report and the top line was
Assad and Isis have been ignoring each
other on the battlefield this has to be
borne in mind Assad is not interested in
fighting Isis and when he does he's
awful at it that's why he loses what is
Russia's motivation besides just
propping up Assad could Russia be trying
to bait the United States into actual
fighting over Syria I think it took them
this long to get involved because they
wanted to see what the US was going to
do you know Putin is paranoid about
American mission creep so Putin probably
thought that eventually the Americans
will realize they have to go after my
client and they'll do a no-fly zone or a
safe zone or something he has now
foreclosed on them because he's created
his own no-fly zone he's testing the
Turks he's his Russian aircraft are
penetrating Turkish airspace and
harassing Turkish fighter jets Fox News
had a thing today that they've been
harassing or chasing American Predator
drones in Syria he's not looking for a
confrontation but he's basically going
like this he's drawing a line in the
sand and he knows we're not gonna cross
it look at what Obama said Obama came
out three days ago and he said two
different things
self contradictory but remarkable one he
said this is Russia Iran and Assad at
war with the majority of the Syrian
people
we have no dog in that fight we're only
at war with Isis but then he said we
will continue our efforts to work with
and build up the moderate Syrian
opposition you can't have it both ways
either you cast the majority of the
Syrian people from which comes the
opposition to their fate against three
militaries or paramilitaries cuz you
have to include Hezbollah in there
or you don't so this was another myth
that was peddled from 2011 Putin has no
personal affection for a bashar no he
doesn't in fact he thinks he's probably
a [ __ ] he wishes his brother bustled
we're running the show because Bassel
would have done with his father did
salted the earth in the very beginning
and destroyed the revolution in in in
embryonic form but he does not repeat
and abandoned his allies this is his
core to who he is he saw how the US
through Mubarak under the bus he watched
as Medvedev acquiesced to the
intervention in Libya and then
essentially the lynching of Gaddafi his
client he will not have that happen with
Assad if only because of the symbolism
the tree policy has been we don't want
to see this regime fall but we want to
sort of diplomatically sweep this all
under the rug and solve the crisis but
we also really don't want to rock the
boat with Iran so how do we do it so
you've had this ambiguous schizophrenic
self-contradictory policy from day one
and the Russians the Iranians the regime
in Syria have all called us on it this
is why what's unfolding is unfolding the
one thing Obama decidedly wanted to do
when he became president on the foreign
policy fund its kind of waged this war
of counterterrorism through Special
Operations raids like the the one that
got bin Laden in Abbottabad cultivate
human you know intelligence by turning
people into spies work with the CIA all
this kind of stuff well if you're now a
Sunni Muslim living in the region and
deemed indispensable are necessary for
spying on Sunni jihadists and helping
the Americans track locate and kill them
what have you just witnessed you have
witnessed the United States just
basically say go [ __ ] yourselves
to all of the clients and assets that's
built up on the ground in Syria doesn't
matter if you want to classify the
Maseca nationalist Islamist or whatever
they were our guys we have abandoned
them two Russian fighter jets they're
being bombed and we're saying sorry
you're on your own how is that going to
affect the way that the United States
wages counterterrorism operations look
I'm out of solutions here you know I can
say I can speak libery about no-fly zone
safe zone but at this point I just
understand this administration is never
going to do anything to try and rescue
the Syrian people or prevent Assad Iran
and Russia from killing everybody they
want to so we got another year in change
of this by that point you know I can
guarantee you the following Assad will
still be in Syria he will still be in
Damascus Isis will still be in Syria you
know Russia's primary objective as I
said destroy us back the opposition and
any alternative to us
that is not nostra or isis eventually
russia will bomb Isis but they haven't
really been doing it well we're gonna
wrap it up there thanks so much for
talking about Michael Weiss the author
of Isis inside the army of terror it's a
great and dense book and clearly he is
well-versed on the subject thank you so
much for talking with Michael thanks my
pleasure four reason TV I'm Anthony
Fischer